isn't that what Magnus is really good at
is taking people away from like making
suboptimal moves to take him away from
the known
uh openings or is that unfair to say
yeah he gets
part of his really dominant reputation I
think from
not letting people get into Ultra
theoretical positions
he just won this tournament this online
tournament and he said he had a young
player strategy he had an anti sorry
anti-young player strategy what's that
mean it means that by move seven or
eight you go to the database no games
the kid is on their own they have to
swim on their own yeah and they have to
deal with the Strategic complexities of
the position which he just he gets and
he might get from just an enormous
database within his brain of historical
games that have similar structures or
just sheer Genius Like We we won't know
yeah it's a mix of the two for sure the
younger you are you can't remember a
game played in 1951 in some bar in the
Soviet Union but he does because he read
a book once or a magazine once and he
just remember just remembers he
remembers the structure which it's just
it's not fair it's crazy right what do
you think makes them if you can sort of
link on it what do you think makes them
so good I think it's the memory and I
think it's
he just seems to get the game better
than anybody else that's the best way I
I can describe it in sports you have
reaction time you have strength you have
but also as he's now evolving it's
stamina
so there have been games that if you put
two other 2750 rated players or world
top 10 players they would have drawn the
game the game would have ended the game
nobody would have won it
you put Magnus as one of the aggressors
in that game
suddenly the chance of Victory doubles
from five percent to ten percent what's
that about because it was a game six
against netball league right uh isn't
stockfish say that it's supposed to be a
draw so 0.00 does mean a draw sometimes
but other times it means since the joke
I always make it means the stockfish is
out for a smoke break
it's just it can you explain the joke
and can you explain 0.00 yes so when so
stockfish will show an evaluation
which determines whether the position is
equal slightly better for one side
slightly better for the other side or
completely winning
you can
0.00.2 minus 0.2 that's all within a
balance you can say okay black has a
little sprinkle of activity something
white has that but if it's zero zero
zero
it could be literally a dead draw
meaning theoretically just impossible to
win but oftentimes what that means is
the smoke break joke is Cypress doesn't
know
there is so much complexity within the
position the combinations of different
moves that are acceptable and okay it
cannot evaluate correctly
wow so even the end games are tough for
stockfish which is why Magnus won that
game because there was practical value
remaining it wasn't a dead draw he
continued to ask questions over the
course of six or seven hours he would
sacrifice a pawn he would sacrifice
another Pawn to damage the structure
evaluation stayed the same
because a machine could stop him
but not young and that was one of my
favorite re that that game ruined my
whole day by the way it destroyed
because yeah I made so many plans that
day it completely ruined my day but it
was a very worthy recap you were just
all in you watched that whole game I
watched the whole game and the world
championship was a crazy time because I
wanted to be first with the recap video
but I also wanted to be best with the
recap video so I spent all the hours of
the games watching all the live
broadcasts and getting all the
information all the variations and
trying to put that into the recap it was
it was a lot of fun it was a huge
adrenaline done when it was all over so
just for people who don't know that's
the most recent World Championship
um so you had a I mean that that was a
draw after draw after dry after dry yeah
and it was It was kind of boring in that
way or maybe
our draws
is there like non-boring Parts within
the draw to you when you were like just
studying it carefully for me yes
for the average viewer no that's the
truth especially when the game itself is
not that exciting when Magnus plays a
strange move on move nine or ten that
hasn't ever been played
and then Jan has to try to exploit it
and he fails and no attack builds up and
they Shuffle their pieces for three
hours my favorite thing is when the
commentators like I don't know why he
did that I wonder why he did that like
yeah when the commentators are confused
that's my as a as a person who's just a
spectator just like
that's that's interesting because then
you the most interesting part is about
listening to the commentators who I
guess themselves might be Grandmasters
uh all yeah they are trying to I guess
just like nepo just like Magnus try to
figure out
what's the idea here what are you
thinking that's cool that's that's
that's an interesting part of the game
but other than that
it's it seemed um
yeah I was sure this is just gonna keep
being a draw especially in that
situation so it's almost it seems almost
remarkable that his uh Magnus was able
to put pull out a win in game six and
after that
now at least Magnus said that that that
ends it because now nepo's gonna have to
take more risks and that opens it up to
Pure chest and then
well as it will um who was it uh Steve
Prefontaine said like whenever it's
whenever there's a race is down to like
pure guts then that's when I win it
there was also a conversation about
eon's
first half second half in any tournament
in the first half he's just brilliant on
fire you could even say he was out
playing Magnus but the entire
conversation before the match was young
slows down and at the first sign of a
loss or a setback
the match might fall apart and that was
the worst way to lose there was
literally no worse way and it just got
worse from there and there I mean it was
one move mistakes and
but he's back
he's the Jan has won the candidates
again he's going to play for the world
championship so who you got who who you
got what is what is this swing
terminology
can we like somehow edit that into a
more sophisticated with the British
accent type of phraseology okay who do
you think will win that match
I think it's 55-45 but I don't know
so it's close it's very close Okay you
can make both cases you could say ding
you could say Jan has been here before
you can say to the world championship
stage he knows what it's like to have a
training camp and so on and so forth his
playing style is very but you can also
say dingly ran is one of the most
stable
unemotional chess players and ding
oftentimes goes from down to up so in
the candidates he lost to Yan in the
very first game 14 Round tournament he
got demolished in the first game I'm
sure he was suffering from jet lag the
flight he he came to Spain like two days
before the games began which was crazy
to me and he got second place by the end
there's chances of finishing in the top
two were like two percent after that
first round game people wrote him off
completely so he doesn't go from top
down he goes the opposite way and if he
loses he might come back but the truth
is I don't know the truth is it's it's
going to be an interesting match and
it's also disappointing we're not going
to get Magnus in it yeah what do you
think about him stepping away from uh
the world championship are you a
romantic about the World Championships
no I'm not a romantic about anything I
don't think I I can't imagine what dark
that went dark quickly I don't think I'm
sophisticated enough to be a romantic I
think I uh you know I I taught chess and
now I make YouTube videos I'm not
qualified on the subject of Romanticism
but I you don't think it's a beautiful
game chess yeah no I think I I think it
is a beautiful there you go I got you
yeah is that is that considered being a
romantic yeah I'm seeing the beauty in
um you can be like Bach and seeing the
math and the music where you can see the
beauty
the magic I think I see beauty in in
certain types of chess for sure not in
all chess so I'll partially romantic
part-time romantic yeah yeah so what I
mean what what do you feel about Magnus
stepping away from the world
championships
disappointing but understandable can you
still man his case what what what's
understandable about it too
I don't think it's as prestigious as it
could be I don't think the World
Championships yeah yeah why does Magnus
still sign everything as world champion
then that's a good point that that he
did just put out a statement and he did
but he does it everywhere else too does
he really yeah like world champion right
world champion I don't know World
Championship World chess champion maybe
it's just because he he he wanted but he
thinks that the journey to the top once
again to maintain the status quo has
lost its appeal well you know what the
example that I like to I like to make I
I'm a big fan of UFC so we've never
really seen with the exception of George
St-Pierre
walking and and could be but khabib was
kind of a different story walking away
from
a belt at the absolute Zenith of their
career but also in the UFC Champions are
extremely well taken care of and the
Champions have some of the best some of
the best lives of course you can argue
not all Champions you can say some of
the lower weight divisions yes but what
I'm saying is a lot of them get all the
sponsors they get massive massive
paydays they're International
celebrities I don't think chess has that
in fact the world championship of Chess
price fund has not changed much in like
40 years so you could probably make more
money on uh on YouTube
yes playing randos not randos but other
having fun and playing challenging
really challenging games playing other
super Grand Masters like an ad hoc
events
or maybe a little bit organized events
but not the world championship yes and
still and still have a lot of fun make a
lot of money
um get everybody excited all that kind
of stuff yeah so for Magna specifically
and we're using him because he's the
world champion if you tally if he wins
every tournament that he plays in over
the course of a year which is really not
even that crazy of an estimate because
that's really how it seems sometimes
yeah I don't know how much money that is
I haven't tallied but if he dedicated an
entire year to being managed on social
media and doing various things and
growing all his Brands and getting
sponsor deals I think he would make five
times more than being the world champion
which is crazy yeah but money isn't
everything I know that's that's totally
able to dedicate their whole life to
winning the Olympics the Olympics is a
funny is an interesting one too because
like I didn't even watch the the
Olympics as carefully as I usually do
this year yeah yeah neither it's it's
really strange I'm not sure why that is
when during covid
I'm not sure that's that was weird I
don't know if it's losing its magic part
of it is also the people that own the
Olympics and the way they distribute it
they make it a little bit more difficult
to watch like it should in my opinion it
should all be just available on YouTube
and
uh easily accessible it's like the
difference between
like uh SpaceX and and uh some other
organ like even NASA because SpaceX is
better at streaming their launches and
commentating them and it they've made
NASA better as well but just like the
ability it sounds ridiculous but
making it more frictionless for people
to watch get excited to share all that
kind of stuff yeah like I'm not exactly
sure where
the magic
like balances between the The Classy
traditional World Championships and the
kind of
dramatic exciting streamer world
and it feels like for for the World
Championships to be relevant they have
to find that balance
yeah well this recent one had I was it's
pretty good commentating yeah no I I'm
not I'm not even necessarily talking
about myself there was a lot of that was
the worst part for me
you did amazing yeah I appreciate that
it was a lot of uh I was a big arms race
so every
major chess platform try to get one
super Grand Master
you name it they were they were
basically involved and to to go back to
that point yeah I the big question is
money and if if Magnus is not motivated
by money if the price went for the next
World Championship was 10 million
dollars would he play it if he says no
Then it must be something else it must
just be a matter of
something's not worth it it's not worth
it you got to take him with his word and
his word is like
there's too much stress to the little
sample play yeah like I want to play
many more times yeah he wants to play
more if he wants to kill him yeah
exactly yeah more shorter games like
where you can
um increase the possibility of Pure
Chess
whatever the heck that means but we
can't go back to the first carp of
Kasparov match which they have to stop
due to health concerns I mean the guy
went down five nil and it was first to
six wins and draws didn't count so draws
didn't amass to the total score there
was no best of system so what happened
there the match went something like
seven eight months Kasparov started
making a comeback after being down five
nothing he was five three and they
called it off they called it off they
said both players are in poor health
conditions because far of stormed down
yelled that this is a farce and but the
match was only 50 games long it would
even more maybe I made a video and I
don't even remember how many games it
was it was so long can you imagine Bobby
Fischer wanted something almost as
extreme draw Stone count its first one
to ten wins and if it's nine nine
the world champion retains his title so
you have to beat the world champion 10-8
that's the only way you don't like that
it's just grueling I don't know maybe I
like it for the YouTube Recaps but do I
like it for the players do I like it for
general public no torture yes three four
hours right you imagine your favorite
tennis match was six months long
what are we doing yeah yeah there's
still magic to the world championship I
wish they could make it some interesting
they make it work somehow
but Matt I think Magnus is really
challenging fide and everybody else to
step up and try to figure that out which
is great ultimately